we begin this morning with a North
Korean ballistic missile test on
president Trump's 100th day in office
the missile apparently exploded shortly
after it was launched north of Pyongyang
the capital North Korea has been
conducting missile and nuclear
weapons-related activities since the
beginning of the year this latest
attempt underscores the North's
determination to develop a nuclear
weapons program in defiance of
international pressure Paula Reid is in
Washington with the latest Paula good
morning good morning on the eve of his
100th day in office President Trump
sought out his supporters at the
National Rifle Association event but
while he was touting his achievements
here at home tensions with North Korea
continued to mount
early Saturday morning in North Korea
Kim jong-un tests launched an
unidentified ballistic missile president
Trump responded by tweeting North Korea
disrespected the wishes of China and its
highly respected president when it
launched though unsuccessfully a missile
today bad the move came just a day after
President Trump warned that the
situation with North Korea could get
worse there's a chance that we could end
up having a major major conflict with
North Korea a US Navy Strike Group and
Japanese destroyers are now operating
within striking range of North Korea a
show of force meant to counter Kim Jong
Un's continued missile tests
earlier Friday President Trump addressed
supporters at an NRA event an early
backer of candidate Trump the
organization spent more money on his
behalf than any other advocacy group as
your president I will never ever
infringe on the right of the people to
keep and bear arms never ever the
president ticked off a list of promises
he is kept in his first 100 days from
the Supreme Court
Neal Gorsuch sits on the bench of the
United States Supreme Court to a decline
in illegal immigration a 73% decrease
never happened before in illegal
immigration on the southern border since
my election but on his 100th day in
office a signature campaign promised to
repeal and replace Obamacare remains
unfulfilled in an interview with Fox
News Friday he expressed frustration
over his party's slow ruling of
legislation I'm disappointed I'll tell
you Paul Ryan's trying very very hard I
think everybody is trying very hard it
is a very tough system the president
will not be attending the annual White
House Correspondents Dinner this evening
in Washington he'll be the first
president since 1981 not to attend the
event instead he will head to
Pennsylvania where he will address
supporters at a rally Alex
Paula Reid in Washington thanks Paula